hey guys how's it going so today I'm
gonna be cooking something that you
don't even actually need to cook I'm
making one of my favorite snacks this is
the no baked Shh I don't think these are
chocolate ones they're no-bake peanut
butter cookies you can also make them as
a chocolate version but we're not gonna
do that let me get my directions we need
three cups of white sugar 3/4 cup butter
1/4 cup milk 1/2 tisp
of vanilla extract 1/2 cup of peanut
butter 4 and 1/2 cups of quick cooking
oats first things first
in a saucepan over medium heat combine
sugar I have to use a saucepan saucepan
this is awesome yeah this looks like a
saucepan ok don't mind my outfit clearly
it's trying to look my best
bring this camera into the shop to get
the shot is I'll bring all my items over
here 3 cups of white sugar coming up one
to follow I'm running low
three 3/4 cup of butter in you go wonder
if I should have milk is first
absolutely no idea this is something
that you could make for a dinner party
for dinner for lunch
did that say three cups of sugar ask
what it says that's what the swiss says
that's what I read I'm gonna burn the
sugar I bet this is probably not gonna
go very well something's gonna go wrong
and I want it to go wrong I'm just
that's what happens I got to bring this
to a boil
Oh God oh boy I should probably get the
oats ready one two three four half okay
make some stuff is starting to happen
here it's definitely starting to get
real right warm says you got a full boil
for a minute this is what a full boil
looks like half this is about oh geez
that looks to be about almost a cup this
is probably about a couple of now I'd
say okay so now I got a I got to point
us into the oats Oh God okay well I'm
gonna pour the mixture into here oh boy
I gotta mix this up so I can't clean it
up yet because the oats need to cook
guys it's so amazing this looks actually
so good I can't believe this might
actually work out well get yourself out
a little cookie pain in it some wax
paper
they just plop these delicious beasts
onto your parchment paper not really
sure how long they take the Harden we'll
find out you can make them smaller if
you wish but I don't wish let's try the
dough and see if it's okay oh my god
it's incredible well let these cool off
and then we'll do a taste test here they
are these are so huge that's how it
tasted one of me Amy we tasted the
batter when it was warm what does it
taste like now honestly this is like the
best this is my most favorite cookie in
the entire world this is definitely not
a healthy treat but it's delicious
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this video and let me
know if you guys have ever tried to make
these or if you have some really good
variations I know my mom used to always
make chocolate ones too so you can also
do that but for now I'm gonna enjoy this
delicious no-bake peanut butter cookie
it's not me so technically not baking I
mean I did have to use a saucepan I'll
see you guys in the next video bye
so God